renault est peut-être née en mai 68 sur
une barricade de la rue gay lussac
il a 16 ans sa première chanson haut
niveau les encouragements de ses copains
et une torgnole de son père le titre
cref [ __ ]
le ton était donné ce ton renault le
maintiendra de laisse béton en 1977
jusqu'à aujourd'hui avec rouge sang le
double album sorti chez virgin music
renault sera en tournée à partir du 23
février prochain et à paris versé du 27
au 29 mars
dans son journal intime renault revient
sur ses origines ni intello me prolos
son grand-père tatoué est sûre ce ventre
de femme qui s'arrondit pour lui refaire
le monde
un monde tout entendre révolution
[Musique]
nemo
et
mais koffi dior les inrocks et
des fois on fout de la gueule de neige
et stéphane labeau fétichiste trop
fanatiques qui vivent jusqu'à ramasser
les mégots mais médiateur sur scène pour
les garder précieusement comme des
reliques
c'est denis coderre gourin et les uns se
marrer c'est de l'amour c'est tout ça du
fétichisme aussi mais c'est de l'amour
voilà la codi d'école que jusqu'à 13 ans
après c'est la mine qui lui a fait la
peau mon grand père oscar steamy
l'origine
sa famille est descendu à 13 ans au fond
de la mine à 20 ans 18 ans dans les
tranchées de la 14è ensuite aux usines
renault billancourt à paris ouvrier
polisseur militants syndicalistes qui
avaient lu marx engels et lénine
à 20 ans et donc c'était un personnage
magnifique il était beau comme un dieu
ici un mètre 90 il était large des pôles
il était tatoué un revenant de la guerre
du tonkin sa femme ma grand mère solange
mériaux à les insulter de cette fête à
tous rire à l'armée a passé sa vie et
tous les matins à se frotter son
tatouage avec un coton imbibé d'eau de
javel
ce qui fait qu'à la fin de sa vie il
était devenu bleu délavé comme un vieux
jean et il fumait la pipe le tabac la
cigarette en paquets ont roulé que j'ai
roulé des journées entières
il est mort de sa fille gens peuvent
être 11 dollars
qui viennent
vim
de ça
mon père et ma mère se sont rencontrés à
paris pendant l'occupation
mais se sont aimés elle était une jeune
secrétaire il était un jeune professeur
d'allemand
écrivain journaliste et voilà ils se
sont aimés pendant 65 ans il venait d'un
milieu social très différents
mon père a enrichi ma mère par avait
rectifié le monde ouvrier
je suis un mélange de ces deux univers
fils d'ouvrier j'aurais pu me serais
paris devenu ce que je suis devenu et
fils de deux intellectuels non plus
peut-être que c'est mélange des deux qui
m'a permis et d'écrire d'un côté et
décrit dans un une langue un peu
populaire et boutiques parfois et
rebelles
ça je dois peut-être que ça ma mère est
le fait d'écrire plus à mon père j'ai
retrouvé mon poids
et puis mai 68 arrive et je découvre la
violence dès les premières
manifestations chez dans la rue et j'ai
fêté mes 16 ans sur les barricades de la
rue gay lussac et la rue royer collard
jeux gratuits y ait un peu de guitare
d'un petit peu de chansons sur deux
trois accords approximatif et j'ai écrit
une chanson et j'ai chanté partout dans
les meetings dans les amphis occupé
devant mes copains et puis rentrant chez
moi par la suite j'ai dit à mes parents
mais je savais quoi j'ai fait une
chanson aimer par l'asie joue je venais
de manifester au quartier j'arrive chez
moi fatigué épuisé mon père me dit
bonsoir fiston comment ça va je lui
réponds ta gueule sale con ça te regarde
pas et je lui ai dit tu rêves [ __ ] et
julie 13 sharon et je veillais crève
poubelles flanc une beigne ouhlala
[ __ ] mon pauvre père vexés humiliés
insultés
c'était une fiction et a versé par la
suite de mes parents recevaient des amis
mais à eux les gens âgés toi un peu ma
mère savait quoi mon fils fait des
chansons d'ailleurs avez vous enchanter
une renault recherche et à la guitare et
moi comme un groupe src reatard
alléchante nous des chansons et moi je
sentis crève [ __ ] et mon père bleynie
c'est de quitter la table furax et sow
et sim aujourd'hui ma fille c'est un
monfils créer une chanson me disant
crayssac on a moins je sais pas sûr que
je serais sûrement pas plus d'humour que
lui à l'époque à m'asseoir sur un banc
cinq minutes avec toi regardez les gens
entendent y en a mais du bon temps
clément roux qui reviendra en serrant
dans maman tu es petit doigt
[Musique]
à
on a bouffé les pigeons idiot filer les
coups de pied pour de faux
entendre ton rire qui les arbres les
murs c'est surtout derrière mes yeux
nous raconter un peu comment j'étais
minot est beau mec fabuleux mais qui est
celle marchand sa came into carmel
enfants les mistral gagnant
[Musique]
pourquoi j'aime spirou et tintin et
lucky luke astérix et et boulimie les
cas seuls hôtesse de l'air passé mon
enfance c'est un royaume idéal que j'ai
perdus qui s'éloigne c'est terrible
quand je lisais j'ai eu dix ans je ne
les ai plus et je n'en reviens pas lisez
l'autre et après j'ai eu une adolescence
aussi très heureuse une vie d'adulte
aussi formidable fabrice ait été touché
par la grâce
dieu des fois je me dis dieu a fait
plouf plouf ce sera toi qui sera eu rope
et c'est tombé sur moi et m'a mis là
dessus et puis puis voilà qui est pire
les années ont passé et puis et puis
dont il ya quelques années
dénommée buck dans les gg je suis tombé
au fond d'un trou qui a duré trois
quatre ans au maximum pendant laquelle
j'ai connu ça ira d'amour dépression je
suis tombé dans la bibine
puis j'ai rencontré romanée et voilà
tous et c'est lié les mains caressent
thabet l'anatomie tous mes yeux
redécouvre la planète inconnue
je deviens aristote retrouver le goût de
la vie le goût de la joie de vivre et le
désir de faire ce que je peux sera chose
que je sais a vaguement faire tout cas
que j'aime vraiment faire c'est écrire
et jouer avec les mots et il les
sentiments qui l'isolent qu'ils
engendrent vous parlez bien vrai je
t'aime
mon regard ce tour lab blonde vert si je
faisais jaune pendant 25 ans points des
co pas miser encore vous une mouette
kizashi dessus quand je sortais chez le
coiffeur
maintenant j'ai cheveux poivre et sel je
les assume à mort je les aime à mort
mais bon pour les canons de la beauté
classique et peut-être dans le regard
des gonzesses
brad pitt et le le canon de la beauté
le maître étalon de la beauté je m'en
branle un peu dans la mesure où ma femme
me dit tous les jours que je suis plus
beau brad pitt en club je pourrais dire
et neige au grenier feu à la cave
j'explore satisfaire cet incroyable
ventre
plus vibrants étendue
[Musique]